أجنبي
[موسيقى]
لذا
أولاً وقبل كل شيء تهانينا ، يجب أن
أخبرك بهذا عندما شاهدت هذا الفيلم ، لقد
استمتعت به حقًا من كل جانب ، لكن
ما يميز هذا الفيلم تستمتع
به عندما تشاهده ولكن عندما تتركه
يعجبك  أكثر من ذلك لأنه ينمو بداخلك ،
هل توافق على
أنني أحب أن أحب ذلك كثيرًا
وأنت تعلم
أنني أفكر بالطريقة التي أفكر بها في صناعة الأفلام
كما أريد شيئًا
سيمنحك تجربة ممتعة في مغامرة
هذه  فيلم وجذاب
حقًا لثقافتنا وفي الشرق الأوسط
نرى ركوب الخيل في الفيلم الذي نشاهده
الصحراء ككاتب ومخرج.
انظر ،
أعتقد أنك تعرف أن كل فيلم يدور حول
أه تصوير عالم ، نعم وأم
أنا أه
عندما كنت أقوم بتشكيل العالم من أجل لا ، فأنت
تعلم أنني فكرت كثيرًا في أنك تعرف
ما هو نوع المكان الذي أريد
قضاء الوقت فيه أين  الجمهور يريد
لقضاء الوقت
في بيئة حيث يمكنك رؤية
كل شيء وكل شيء واضح
وشعرت أنه إذا كان بإمكاني أن أجعلهم يخافون في
تلك البيئة ، فسأكون قد أخرجتهم
شيئًا ما هنا ، هل أنت الشخص الوحيد
في العالم الذي يمكنه الحصول على  في
فيلم
تلك السحابة قاموا بتحريك الحافة ،
هناك الكثير من مقاطع الفيديو للطيران القرف
عبر الإنترنت ، ولن يحصل أحد على
ما سنحصل عليه ما الذي
سنحصل عليه ما الذي
حدث كيف استعدت للدور دانيال
آه نعم  كان عليّ فعل الكثير لأنني أمضيت
ثلاثة أسابيع للاستعداد
ولم أكن أعرف كيف أركب
في التصوير ، سأذهب يوم الأحد إلى
مزرعة ثم أتعلم وأشياء من هذا القبيل
نعم و  ثم ذهبت إلى المزرعة أيام
السبت وقمت بتنظيف المتاجر لأنني
لم أكن أرغب في أن تبدو وكأنها
النمر الفارغ المزيف وهذا الامتياز
مميز جدًا في المملكة العربية السعودية ، فقد كان أول
فيلم يتم طرحه في دور العرض في
المملكة العربية السعودية.  ما هو شعورك
حيال كونك جزءًا من  التاريخ
في المملكة العربية السعودية ، نعم ، أنا محظوظ جدًا ،
أحب دبي ،
لقد اشتريت واحدة كنت في دبي عندما كنت في
عام 1998.
إنه لأمر رائع أن أكون جزءًا من
تاريخ المملكة العربية السعودية أمر
مذهل  كأنك
ستغادر هنا ،
أنا
أتحدث إليك
يا أخي ، ماذا كنت سترى شخصًا فوق
السحاب كبير جدًا ، سأكون كبيرًا ،
هل تعتقد أن كل ما يتعلق بقتل الملوثات العضوية الثابتة
هناك
منذ أن ذكرت الميزانية للتو
قال السيد بيل أن هذا  لم يكن الفيلم
ممكنًا قبل خمس سنوات ، لكن
هوليوود اليوم أكثر تنوعًا
وفرصًا أكثر ، ما رأيك في
ذلك ، نعم أعتقد أنه حقيقي وأعتقد
أنه كان لديه الكثير ليفعله حيال ذلك ، كما تعلم ،
وضع الأشخاص الملونين في  يؤدي
والموضوع الذي لا يتعلق دائمًا
بالأسود مقابل الاضطهاد ، إنه
مجرد أوراق سوداء لا يزال الأردن
واضحًا جدًا في رؤيته كما أتذكر
عندما قمت برسم حبوب المفاتيح كنت أعمل
معه مباشرة أيضًا وكان
يوجهني و  كل تلك الأشياء
وكانت تجربة ممتعة
صدقك أنت كتبت هذا الفيلم وأخرجته
وأخبرنا عن عملية
صنع هذا الفيلم
كان هذا أه
واحد إن لم يكن التحدي الأكبر في
حياتي أه صنع هذا الفيلم كان هناك
شيء في هذا السعي الذي أه
ذاك الفكرة التي أم أنا  أنا في موقف
حيث يجب أن أكون طموحًا ويجب
علي
أن أفعل شيئًا
ما
سيساعد الناس على إعادة تأكيد
حبهم للخروج إلى السينما والخروج إلى
دور السينما وهذا نوع من ما
أذهلني بالفيلم
لأنه يجتمع معًا ،
هل تعلم أنك تراه نوعًا ما يمس
نوع الرعب الذي تراه يلامس النوع الكوميدي
الذي تراه يلمس اه مغامرة
الخيال العلمي الغربي
وكان لدي هذا
الشعور بأنه يجب أيضًا أن يمثل
الفرح  والهروب من
ظلام العالم كذلك شكرا جزيلا
لرؤيتك مرة أخرى